what you're about to watch is a nebula
original meaning it was first released
on nebula the streaming site founded by
myself and plenty of other creators
producing this documentary was an
enormous project which involve flying
myself and a crew 10,000 miles to one of
the most remote places on earth and it
was entirely funded by curiosity stream
that's because curiosity stream has
partnered with nebula to offer a bundle
deal where if you sign up at curiosity
stream comm slash Wendover you also get
a nebula subscription easy as that on
there you'll find loads of other great
originals by independent creators but
for now - the documentary
[Music]
you
it was this precise moment early on a
Saturday afternoon in October 2017 that
changed the course of history for one of
the world's most remote societies this
moment that ended 500 years of isolation
from the world
cutting travel time to their from six
days on a boat to six hours on a plane
it was this small moment
that changed everything for the island
an island where the thing they need most
of all as much as it might hurt is
change it was this moment that long in
the future will be recognized as the
single most consequential ever for the
island of st. Helena you'd be forgiven
for not knowing exactly what or where
santolina is it's not a place that one
hears a whole lot about if you have
heard of it
that's likely thanks to Napoleon it's
here on st. Helena where the infamous
emperor of France was exiled by the
British for these six years preceding
his death since then though the own has
been up to quite a bit it's now home to
about 4,500 of the friendliest people
you'll ever meet
walking a block through its capital of
Jamestown it's tough to go without
saying hi in hello a half-dozen times
driving past someone without giving a
wave well that's practically a crime
Saints as the residents are called are
is proudly British as they come and fly
their Union Jack's copiously and
conspicuously the island is after all a
British overseas territory life on
santolina is quite unlike life in the UK
though they've got their own money their
own accents their own culture their own
government but most of all what makes
life on st. Helena different is where it
is the island sits in the same
neighborhood as nothing mainland Africa
is 1,100 miles or 1,800 kilometers to
its east mainland South America is about
2,000 miles or 33 hundred kilometres to
its West London is over 4600 miles or
7,500 kilometers to its north st.
Helena's isolation defines and shapes it
in absolutely every way including
perhaps most consequentially
economically you see santolina is not a
wealthy place its GDP per capita
averages just above 12,000 dollars
compared to about 40,000
dollars in the UK the issue is that
getting people and things to and from
the middle of nowhere costs a great deal
so there just aren't too many industries
that can profitably operate on a place
as tiny and isolated as st. Helena
the Saints have found a few though
beyond the traditional goods and
services sectors that any small
community would have Saint Helena does
have exports coffee we had some of the
rarest coffee in the world which sells
for I know ninety two hundred pounds in
the United Kingdom for just one hundred
grams if we could increase that to some
extent that would bring revenue to many
of the farmers on the island they also
sell a good amount of tuna and honey but
then there's another sector that
capitalizes on the islands isolation the
predominate economy here at the moment
is there is niche tourism diving history
naturally for natural hist no walking to
us bird-watching those sorts of things
plus also a growing market of people who
want to get away from it all a one week
away from the internet and given the
internet prices here and that's quite
easy to achieve if you want to do it but
tourism would be nothing without a means
to get off and on to st. Helena Island
it was only recently that this became
something the government had to worry
about in the early days of the islands
human history shipping was what brought
a population to it it was the perfect
stopping point on the route from the Far
East to Europe around the Cape of Good
Hope so perfect in fact that if for a
while the entire island was run by the
British East India Company eventually
though the Suez Canal opened and so
fewer boats would round the southern tip
of Africa this of course diminished
saline has importance but still up until
the 1970s the island served as a regular
stopping point for ocean liners
traveling between the UK and South
Africa meaning there was a reliable link
to the outside world but then throughout
the 20th century as air travel grew more
popular and profitable passenger ocean
liners around the world increasingly
struggled to fill their ships and one by
one
down the last shipping line with
passenger services Angelina collapsed in
1977 leaving the island marooned with no
way to get to the outside world the
British stepped in buying a ship for
their overseas territory which would be
called the RMS Saint Helena the RMS was
part cargo ship parked passenger ship in
the front she carried dozens of shipping
containers actually as the primary
supply line for the island and in the
back she was adorned with pools and bars
and sun loungers her regular journey
consisted of the five nights from Cape
Town to st. Helena then she would
continue on to Ascension Island in two
or three nights where she would meet and
connect her passengers to one of the
bi-weekly Royal Air Force flights to the
UK this method via Ascension allowed
travelers to get from the UK to st.
Helena in relative speed just four days
most though took the longer route from
South Africa locals and tourists alike
adored the RMS she was thought of as the
perfect transition from st. Helena to
the outside world or vice versa
she was a legendary storied vessel but
after decades of heavy use shuttling
passengers to and from the island in the
early 2000s the RMS was getting old and
worn and the government started to think
about what would replace her initial
assessments found that replacing the
ship would cost up to 100 million
dollars this led to the question with
that kind of money was a ship really the
best option the answer it turned out was
probably not after decades of
feasibility studies discussions debates
false starts delays and bidding a
contract was produced and with a few
quick signatures life on st. Helena
would change forever st. Helena was
getting an airport the contract was
signed in November 2011 and that's when
basil read arrived on the island to
start basically looking at the
infrastructure logistics they started
the first construction or the first
moving of soil in 2015 November and
obviously they built various roads up to
the airport because there to get the
logistics up to the airport
they also had a ship they brought in all
the
materials logistics all the space
equipment they had to obviously help to
build the airport so they constructed it
over four years at the end of 2015 the
runway was completed most of the
terminal buildings were completed most
of the CNS equipment which is
communication and navigation equipment
was installed and the airport was
reading for a certification at the end
of October 2015 new airports are rare
new airports and places that have never
had an airport before or even rarer
giving an empty husk of an airport
certified and staffed is no easy task
for this to happen on st. Helena
subcontractors were streaming through
the islands there were audits upon
audits upon audits staff members were
recruited locals were trained both on
and off Island for jobs like security
immigration firefighting and more
emergency procedures were written public
meetings were conducted airport vehicles
were shipped in instruments were
calibrated beacons and localizers and
obstacle lights were installed a logo
was designed calibration flights came in
emergency drills were conducted drill
mods were codified operational trials
were run and then finally in February
2016 the airport was certified and ready
to open commercial flights could start
and Saint Helena would achieve its
decades-long ambition of having an air
link to the outside world there was just
one more step as one last hurdle of
bureaucracy Comair the airline
contracted to operate flights to sing
alina wanted to perform an
implementation flight as they called it
essentially they were going to fly one
of their planes in to test that
everything from the instruments to the
runway to the terminal to the fuel
system worked now Comair was really the
perfect airline to connect st. Helena to
the world they're a British Airways
franchisee meaning they are contracted
by British Airways to operate their
regional flights from South Africa and
therefore fly a number of routes around
the region under the British Airways
brand the plan was for column air to
operate a British Airways route nonstop
from Johannesburg to st. Helena these
flights would seamlessly connect to
other British Airways flights to the two
locations Saints travel most
Cape Town and London as well as with
hundreds of other destinations around
the world with the exception of a direct
flight to the UK there's really nothing
better st. Helena Airport could have
wished for they just had to do the
implementation flight so on one sunny
nearly cloudless April day in 2016
a calm air 737 appeared off in the
distance to the north of st. Helena
Airport carrying a handful of staff
members of the airline and airport
construction company it approached
wheels up in order to perform a fly
buying above the runway as planned after
gaining altitude again it's circled back
around in order to make a second and
final approach but then just seconds
away from touchdown there was a sort of
wobble then another one then once it's
wheels were just feet above the runway
the pilots elected to abort the landing
go around and give it another shot so
the plane circled around again and after
some more wobbling came to a landing the
first ever landing of a commercial
passenger jet on the island even if it
wasn't carrying commercial passengers
Saint Helena was thrilled I'm here with
DES Rhys Alun directed D and E akka Dion
you just arrived on the first passenger
jet to land here on st. Alena can you
describe the experience great experience
I mean it's just the cherry on the cake
off to the four years work Friday Friday
morning I flew act on the AC flat I win
time spend the weekend with the family
played golf yesterday and today I'm back
on the island and I mean that's the
signs of the times and that's the whole
reason for the airport is to be able to
travel back and forth as you please
Susan obey and gram vests course you
were here to witness the first-ever
passenger passenger jet land on st.
Alena I'm first of all you gram how does
it feel can you describe the experience
it was absolutely amazing and I feel
really privileged to be here at this
momentous occasion it really is such a
historic event I feel absolutely
wonderful I feel proud of everything
that's been done by you guys on the
island thank you and you Susan
excited extremely excited this is like
the culmination of weeks months years of
hard work as far back as 2005 and we're
really really proud of everything that's
been achieved today this is the first
step you know a plane land unless
Antonina what this does now mean for
tourism one second you know well now
we've got the Gateway to get people here
before we had to rely on the ship the
rms coming backwards and forward this
means we can have a steady stream at
first it'll be that Saturday flight
people get used to and then once that's
being filling up hopefully we'll have a
midweek one and that's the way we can
really develop tourism and it becomes
worth people investing in restaurants
bars other things that will help the
tourists here so the start of a new era
for st. Alena everyone was ecstatic but
at the time nobody fully understood what
had just happened you see this little
waffle just before landing had just
derailed the decades-long plan for st.
Helena's new era that wobble was
evidence of wind shear a phenomenon
where wind traveling in one direction
meets when traveling in another
direction and creates a zone of
turbulent air in st. Helena's case it's
wind shear was due to the already strong
wind being pushed around and rerouted by
the enormous cliffs at the northern end
of its runway when coming into land an
airplane wind is already a hassle but
when it quickly shifts is in the case of
wind share it can be a lot worse
the first sign to the general public
that something was wrong was when the
st. Helena government postponed the long
scheduled airport opening ceremony which
was planned to be presided upon it by
Prince Andrew eventually it emerged that
the solution would be to land planes
from the south as there was not a wind
share issue from this direction but this
did have its own issues planes generally
like to land into the wind as this
allows them to stop faster on the runway
but at the airport wind almost always
comes from the south meaning planes
would be landing with a tailwind in
order to successfully land a 737 with a
tailwind
on the length of runway offered at st.
Helena the 737 would have to be quite
light it wouldn't be able to take its
full capacity of passengers or cargo in
fact it would have to shed so much
weight that the flight would never be
commercially profitable for calm air
even with the planned subsidies and so
unceremoniously it was announced that
calm air and therefore British Airways
would not be running the flights to st.
Alena eventually the story of Saint
Helena Airport reached the world the
British tabloids got their hands on it
and ripped it to shreds they called the
airports embarrassing a gaffe a folly a
farcical vanity project much of what was
reported wasn't even accurate tabloids
said it was impossible to land they said
the airport was closed neither of which
was true in fact throughout the delay
private and medevac flights were coming
in and out with no problem the media
latched on to the video of that calm air
implementation flight and as one outlet
called it the terrifying three attempts
it took to land in reality it was one
planned fly by one aborted landing and
one successful landing in the world of
commercial aviation aborted landings are
nothing exceptional they happen many
times a day at airports large and small
all around the world most of all though
the common thread between all the media
reports with the nickname Saint Helena
Airport received the world's most
useless airport that was the one that's
done and I think a lot of the sort of
initial label given by the popular media
has not helped the island and I think
it's totally false quite frankly we knew
that st. Lina was going to get a lot of
flack over it from the media we didn't
quite appreciate how much it was going
to feature but it became a lot about how
bad the British government had done in
investing in the airport on st. Lina and
putting it in the wrong place
essentially when the bad press hit of
saints of the you know heaven white
elephant for airport I was really angry
and stole two today in my professional
capacity
we are contouring and battling to get
rid of that negativity it is really bad
and people doesn't want to see the goop
that is actually happening since all of
those articles we've had to spend a lot
of time I suppose trying to sell the
island for its positive aspects and also
show you know things like there's only
been one cancellation in there the
entire year this year but those things
are harder to get through than the
sensation this stuff ourselves papers
you always have startin out problems and
what would you expect we are in the
middle of the South Atlantic this is the
first time for it to happen so you gotta
have trial and error and I wish people
would just leave the air and outside and
look at what is happening as a result in
order to shrug off that nickname they
needed of course a flight so we had to
do a lot of research so we commissioned
our UK Met Office to do a lot of
research on our wind daughter so we
collated a lot of wind otter over six
months 12 months so we could ascertain
exactly what the conditions were on
runway 2 0 & 1 ways over to once we got
all that dot into place then the sh t
government went up with a new tender
looking for an aircraft that could
actually land runway 0 2 which had a 15
not tailwind component it was runway 2-0
that had the wind shear issue not runway
0 - these two are in fact the same
physical runway but runway 2 0 refers to
the landing coming from the North runway
0 2 refers to the landing from the south
the prevailing winds originated from the
south so the key to a safe landing was
an aircraft small enough to stop safely
within the length of the runway even
when wind pushes it from you high
that way if the wind shear from the
north is too bad it can land from the
south the service was not to be
subsidized but rather underwritten there
isn't a subsidy per passenger so they
don't get paid let's say 10 pounds per
passenger per flight at all it's very
much a commercial service but if that
commercial service makes a loss that
loss is underwritten by DFID in the UK
two main bidders emerged to operate the
flights to saint alina the first was a
company called atlantic star airlines
founded in 2012 still the early days of
the airport construction process
atlantic star was created specifically
to serve as an airline for santolina
their original plan was to make weekly
flights directly from London to st.
Helena via some Midway refuelling stop
in addition to a weekly flight to Cape
Town it was an ambitious plan but they
were serious about it the company
consisted of seasoned aviation
executives and professionals including a
CEO who came from British Airways over
time though the plane was scaled back to
operating a few charter flights a year
from London to st. Helena by a ban jewel
in The Gambia this was going to happen
they had an agreement with tui Airlines
to charter a 737 they had announced
schedules they had set fares but then of
course the airport's opening was delayed
and these flights were all canceled
after some time in October 2016
Atlantic star came back into the story
by chartering an Avro RJ 1000 to fly to
the island and run a series of tests
landings a move the company tried to use
as evidence of their legitimacy and the
bidding process the proposal was that
they would lease an Avro jet to be based
on santolina as the island dedicated
aircraft twice a week they would fly the
hour and a half north to Ascension
Island to connect with the bi-weekly RAF
flights to the UK having the aircraft
based on saying Elina would according to
their bid be quite the benefit for the
island considering that it could at a
moment's notice
fly medical evacuation flights rather
than waiting for a plane to fly in from
South Africa to
a patient up ultimately though the bid
failed
the other major bid submitted to the st.
Helena government was by a South African
airline called air link their plan was
to fly an Embraer e190 chat to say
Galena once weekly on Saturdays the
aircraft would fly from Johannesburg to
Windhoek Namibia where would meet
another service coming in from Cape Town
this connecting structure was viewed as
quite important since while most of the
sate diaspora is in Cape Town
Johannesburg is the larger airports and
offers more connections from win hook
who would then fly the three hours over
the South Atlantic to land in st. Elina
it would then do the same in Reverse
included in air links bid was an
agreement to operate once monthly
charter flights from st. Alina
to Ascension Island as an add-on to
their flight from Johannesburg giving
that island which primarily serves as a
military base for the UK and us it's
only regularly scheduled non-military
flight to the outside world this bid was
as close to perfect st. Helena was going
to get on July 21st 2017 the st. Helena
government signed a contract with
Airlink and announced to the world that
this tiny South Atlantic outpost was
finally getting its connection to the
world st. Helena was getting a flight
for real this time a few months later
just over a year after that Comair
flight had arrived in the skies above
st. Helena an air link Embraer e190 to
the same it was filled with 70 or so
journalists tourists and Saints and soon
enough safely touched down and was
greeted by well a big proportion of st.
Helena that was Saint Helena's before
and after moments once those wheels
touch down st. Helena would never be the
same but once that happened once the
honeymoon period was over it was time
for st. Helena to get to work
realizing the full potential of the
airport was no easy task of course the
natural environment presented its own
issues but the true challenge lies in
the islands geographic isolation and
political independence which mean that
in all aspects the airport has to be
entirely self-sufficient they're not run
by some big company they're not part of
any national system st. Helena Airport
is run by Saint Helena Airport limited
and if
Gweneth Howell its CEO doesn't know what
to do there's not really anyone she can
call that means that everything needed
to run st. Helena Airport from
administrative to operational has to
happen at st. Helena's Airport it turns
out that even with just one weekly
flight that's quite a lot so what we
have is for example in this in this room
here we have what's called CNS so
communication navigations and
surveillance so we have two two guys
when he works on IT sign of things one
who works on the navigation aids and so
on and they're really crucial to the
running of the airport now without the
communication navigation system without
those kind of IT systems in place we
wouldn't be able to land aircraft and
takeoff aircraft here at the at the
airport so it's extremely important CEOs
office obviously we need a chief
executive officer for Centennial Airport
Limited and then as my office next door
I'm kind of the CEOs right-hand person
so I will always be there to support
them but I'm also kind of separate as
well because I'm meant to be there to be
the conscience almost off of the of the
company to do the thinking to do the
questioning why are we doing it like
that could we do it another way could we
do it a safer way could you do it a
better way so that's a pretty important
role so if we carry on that this way
actually this is an important room to
look in it's the gym and it's where our
professed team keep fit it's being in
there in the firefighting services it's
a very physical job so you need to be
fit all the time and in fact there are
fitness levels to be met so the gym is
an important part of that hello bill
security and because I'm not security
cleared I can't go in there even though
I'm sort of senior management team there
are still levels of security that some
of us can't get get into and this is one
room that I'm not permitted to go into
and rightly so so if you want to follow
me down to in the rest of the combined
building so we have a training room so
there's an awful lot of training that
goes on
for staff we need to meet we need to be
accredited in many respects so there's a
lot of training that goes on security in
particular but also firefighting as well
so that's our training room and walking
on further down we also have a
maintenance bay as well which I'll
briefly open the door and walk in
so the maintenance Bay's is where we
obviously maintain equipment we have a
lot of equipment to maintain and we have
an on-site mechanic who does so so we
also use it for storage as well so this
for example is a Tobias tug allows us to
to tow aircraft if we need to another
bits of pieces like the the toilet cart
and so on so it's a it's a multi-purpose
Bay we use it for storage and we use it
for for maintaining our vehicles so for
moving along finally come to the end
it's the most important room in the
building because these people make sure
we get paid so here we have good
afternoon
we have HR and finance extremely
important to running a small but compact
Airport but nevertheless now there's all
the HR and the financial functions that
go with that in addition to all the
administrative functions st. Helena
Airport well it might need less of it
needs all the same things that an
enormous airport like Heathrow would
mean a striking example of this is the
fire service ICAO regulation basically
states that every airport have to have
some sort of firefighter category it
really depends on the movement of the
aircraft within that airfield
that's regulation and that is what we
have to provide we are always on standby
so if there's an aircraft emergency
right now and we get the crash alarms go
we can provide a three-minute response
to
let's despite the fact that most days
there isn't a single aircraft within
hundreds of miles of the island but
nonetheless it's what's required by
regulation even at an airport with
thousands of weekly flights it's not as
if firefighters are responding to fires
all that often which means that there's
no real reason for those airports to
have more than one firefighting crew the
result is that an airport like st.
Helena which has a one or two commercial
flights a week needs firefighting
capabilities pretty similar to an
airport like Heathrow which has
thousands that's part of what balloons
the cost of running such a small airport
given the isolation of the island
weather forecasting is another crucially
important yet challenging part of what's
needed to keep the weekly flight
reliable and safe the UK Met Office
station's meteorologists on st. Helena
on more or less yearly rotations after a
Saturday flight I usually have the
Sunday or Monday off so when I come in
on Tuesday that's when I first start
looking at what the weather's going to
be like for the next flight day which is
usually the Saturday as we get nearer to
the time we start I start to do more
detailed forecasts for the airline so on
a Friday I produce a detailed forecast
for their estimated time of arrival on
the Saturday and then I come in at four
o'clock on the Saturday morning and
update that forecast and forward that to
the fly operations the reason this is so
important is so that they know when an
aircraft is supposed to get to st.
Helena Airport it'll be able to land at
st. Helena Airport the main problem is
because of the remoteness of the
airfield there are no nearby diversions
so they can't arrive here and spend two
hours circling and then divert to a
nearby airfield if they come here then
they've got to be 99 percent convinced
that they're going to be able to land so
I will be looking at cloud base and
visibility as they major things that
would stop them from landing at San
Halina the reason being because of their
restrictions they have to be visual with
the airfield before they can land so if
the cloud base is below 900 feet then
they won't be able to see the air
field before their decision height
assuming the airline has that required
level of confidence that the flight will
be able to successfully land at st.
Helena air link will give it clearance
to depart from Johannesburg at about
9:00 a.m. local time it will then make
the two-hour flight to Walvis Bay in
Namibia a more or less regular flight at
Walvis Bay they'll refuse tanks giving
them about six hours of flying time but
also at this table they'll have to once
again decide whether they'll be able to
land at st. Helena this time the level
of confidence has to be higher than it
was even in Johannesburg but assuming
they are confident the flight will take
off climb to altitude and begin its
three-hour ocean crossing but the
decisions still aren't over throughout
this crossing the airline will be
continuously evaluating the conditions
on the island to assure they'll be able
to land and if they believe they can't
they'll turn back for Namibia assuming
they continue on eventually they will
then approach the island drop altitude
and connect by radio with the airport's
air traffic controller but then even
once there if the cloud levels are too
low or the wind is too strong the planes
still won't be able to land so when they
get here and they're not able on the
first attempt to land they will do a
go-around they will go into a holding
pattern and they will wait for a few
minutes based on what we have in terms
of satellite image for the weather it
could be 10 minutes could be five
minutes it could be as soon as they go
around when they come back they can see
the runway and then they'll be able to
do a landing so in the unlikely event
that a successful landing cannot be
completed then the aircraft will have to
dive at st. Elena's closest diversion
point is Ascension Island it's about an
hour and a half flight north so this is
likely where any flight would divert if
landing at st. Helena was not possible
there they have fuels and facilities so
the air link flight could give landing
on st. Helena another shot the day after
in the time that st. Helena Airport has
been open no commercial flight has ever
failed landing and had to divert in fact
in the first 10 months of 2019 the
airport didn't even have a single
cancelled
flights every Saturday at about 1:15
p.m. an air link Embraer e190 has
reliably pierced through the clouds
above st. Helena's Airport ready to drop
off another load of eager tourists and
wistful locals Saturdays at st. Helena
Airport are an event despite its tiny
size people start arriving at the
building three or four hours in advance
of the flight while the plane might only
seat 96 people every flight sees a crowd
far larger has extended families of
every synched arriving and leaving seem
to show up just for the flight day there
opens a bank branch a gift shop a
luggage wrapping business a cafe and a
restaurant those not taking the flights
will stand in the check-in hall looking
to see who's leaving then make their way
up to the restaurant once the passengers
pass through security then as the time
draws near
everyone packs into the observation deck
far busier than that of any of the
world's largest airports and look to the
left it's reminiscent of sailors
watching to be the first to see land but
in this case it's Saints trying to be
the first to see their link to the
outside world a world that some of them
have only seen through screens they try
to spot the small metal tube that
represents the link between them and us
with patience the time comes and the
Embraer e190 appears in st. Helena's
skies it makes its approach usually
jostled around by the consistently
inconsistent winds then passes the
daunting cliff at the end of the runway
then glides smoothly into touchdown
that's when the airport truly comes
alive only 75 minutes sits between the
scheduled landing time and the scheduled
takeoff time each Saturday so as soon as
the aircraft takes its right turn
towards the apron there begins a
carefully choreographed dance
the aircraft is marshaled in then first
to approach are the air stairs followed
by the ground power unit that gives
energy to the aircraft when it's it's
powered down while the cleaners approach
the aircraft the baggage compartment of
the aircraft has opened the fuel truck
gets into position and the first
passengers start to disembark with
certain jobs only needing to happen once
a week quite a few staff at the airport
work multiple jobs the firefighters for
example go straight from their truck
assure
that the aircraft has landed safely to
handling baggage at the back of the
aircraft all the sewage from the
laboratory has to be emptied and an
amulet is used to lift passengers with
reduced mobility on and off the pilots
qualified to land at st. Helena are
among the most senior and experienced at
air link which means there are fewer
than ten pilots who work the route
therefore they visit the island on
average about once a month but since the
aircraft only stays there for just over
an hour have never seen more of the
island than the airport during their
time on the island though they'll
perform a safety inspection of the plane
and then soon enough it'll be time to
load up boarding the 96 or fewer
passengers doesn't take long and quickly
the door will close their stairs will
pull away and the aircraft will taxi
back to the runway it will take a turn
to the north roll its way down to the
end of the runway turn around then
Thunder down st. Helena's spotlessly
clean piece of pavement to take off on
it's four and a half hour trip back to
Johannesburg with that the clock starts
ticking again as the airport preps for
its next 75 minutes in the spotlight and
then everyone makes their way to their
homes or hotels starting their next week
of isolation from the world of course
the Saints love the airport while
they're at it while they're standing in
the observation deck watching the plane
fly off destined for Johannesburg in a
quake four and a half hours for those
that have lived their entire lives on
santolina
the prospect of getting to South Africa
in a matter of hours still seems like
magic once people go home though the
question that comes up frequently in
conversation is was it worth it 2013 and
2014 when they were both in the airport
was a big significant boom for santolina
the amount of people that were in and
out of the island a lot of saint
athenians or airplane for the first time
in their life the economy was actually
thriving so it was a bold up to what was
the airport going to bring for st. alina
I would say people expected the airport
to bring quite significant change now
whether those expectations were
reasonable is is something
that is perhaps debatable the
once-a-week flight is okay but at the
end of the day if you're bringing in a
plane which can carry potentially 90
passengers that's not enough to be able
to generate a significant increase in
the footfall on st. Lena I think there's
an expectation that the service perhaps
isn't delivering what it should but I
think we also have to take into account
the fact that we will still not try
we're still a relatively untested market
both for tourists and also for potential
their investors looking at the graphs
the airport has had some effect in the
12 months after its opening 3337 people
arrived on the island by plane that's
compared to just two thousand six
hundred and sixteen passengers who had
arrived the previous 12 months on the
RMS in the airport's second year of
operations four thousand one hundred and
eighty-eight passengers arrived via the
airport which certainly is a measurable
improvement although overall visitor
arrivals to the island stayed about the
same
is there was a period of overlap between
the start of flights and the end of the
RMS service it's tough to measure the
true success of the airport yet just two
years into service but what sure is that
there has been no tourism explosion
flights are expensive infrequent and
indirect for everyone by South Africans
and this has kept the island a niche
destination the island certainly had to
hurry up and wait as well the first
flight might have been the impetus for
change it certainly didn't change
everything overnight success for st.
Helena Airport however cannot be
measured solely by visitor numbers it
can also be measured in lives the number
of lives this solitary piece of pavement
has saved I was in my last trimester
fairly normal pregnancy up until the
last where my blood pressure
kind of
so the concern was preeclampsia and they
decided that I needed an emergency this
area so he can heal I was born about all
weeks earlier than then except that he
we had him around half sux Wednesday
evening and he had he had a bit of a
restless 90-day breathing wasn't so good
although that was to be expected because
of the c-section the next morning the
Midwife came in and she said no
breathing wasn't normal and they decided
to put him on the ventilator and
heaviness asked so they did so many
tests and he had respiratory distress
syndrome and about like 11:00 on
Thursday night doctor Kevin O'Brien and
Helen Lawrence came in so I want to said
that it said that he would need to be
Mary Beth out if there are masters on
his last journey to the UK so the best
reaction was how do we get him out and
then it was we were told that they had
already decided to get a medevac flight
in two days after Eli was born on a
Friday afternoon a small jet from a
South African medical evacuation company
touched down at st. Helena Airport
representing only the fourth arrival by
a fixed-wing aircraft to the island the
team spent the afternoon evaluating
Eli's condition and then early the
following morning him and his mother
Patrice were transferred by ambulance to
the airport and brought onto the Jets
after a quick four hours crossing the
South Atlantic they touched down in Cape
Town and by 2:00 p.m. local time arrived
at Vincent lawdy Hospital with all the
facilities
Eli needed just about five hours after
leaving the hospital he's
if it wasn't for the airport then I
really thought that Eli we have made it
it would have been a long wait for the
RMS to come down like another month and
then the weeks travel to Cape Town he
probably wouldn't have made it waiting
for the month for the ship to actually
get there so now without the airport I
don't think you know I would have made a
bit of survived today Eli is a perfectly
healthy young boy he's one of the
handful of Saints who quite directly owe
their lives to the airport
isolation is dangerous in st. Helena's
Hospital just isn't equipped to handle
advanced medical conditions before the
airport that medical risk just came with
the territory and in some cases survival
was down to luck the luck of where the
RMS was on its voyage schedule one can't
easily argue against anything that saves
lives no matter the cost but the truth
is that when the British government
spent their hundreds of millions of
dollars to build st. Helena Airport they
had more than the humanitarian benefits
in mind in the two years since its
opening the airport has brought change
but it has not yet fundamentally
transformed what st. Alena is I think
that the potential for the island is
actually really really quite strong
and I think that but I think as with all
emerging destinations it's going to take
a while what I think is is worrying
though is that for a lot of people it's
how long will that wild be is it going
to be five years ten years 20 years
nobody really knows long term the
airport ambition is of course to grow
the islands economy the UK's Department
for International Development conducted
a business case for the airport way back
in 2010 and developed a tourism growth
estimate for santolina based on how
other similar islands fared in the
industry after improving their access
this model starting at about 1,000
tourists per year in 2016 projected
growth to 30,000 yearly tourists in 2040
- a number that has been subject to
intense scrutiny everywhere from the
Saint Alina dinner table to the
Parliament of the United Kingdom the
data show though that accounting for the
one-year delay in the airport's opening
current visitor arrivals are exactly on
target for this growth what that means
is that the airport project is not
doomed from the start but will determine
its success is what's to come and the
Christmas 2019 season is bringing
something promising sold-out flights the
holidays are by far the most popular
season for travel to st. Helena and with
that in months of December January and
February air link has added Tuesday
flights from Cape Town a first for the
islands in addition there's another
promising sign in their first year of
operation the flights actually turned a
small profit for air link longer turn
the island has ambitions for an even
more extensive network of flights one
goal would be to get a route to a South
American city like a CV to allow for a
more direct route from the Americas
technically this would be feasible as
it's only a 4-hour flight commercially
though that's another question also on
the wish list is a round trip flight to
Namibia to tap into their large tourism
market however the largest tourist
demographic for the island by far is
British and so the crown jewel of routes
would be to the UK since before the
airport even opened there's been talk of
a route to lund
via Cape Verde right now though these
are all just dreams an airline would
only take the enormous risk of starting
around to st. Helena if it proved not
only commercially viable but successful
that has not happened yet the next
couple years for santolina are crucial
as the number of successful completed
flights ticks up data will prove whether
they're sticking to this line the line
that will determine whether st. Helena
will survive economically into the far
future if they stick to it they're in
for an economic Renaissance if they
start to fall below it there's little
hope for any sort of self-sufficiency
meaning the island will remain at the
mercy of the UK's budgetary allocations
the Saint Helena was never supposed to
change overnight and the airport was
never supposed to be a magic cure-all
the airport's is a tool for change not
the impetus of change itself for the
islands to fundamentally change it has
to sell itself to the world it has to
one by one convince people to come to it
to invest in it to take a risk on a
place that's competing with an entire
world of options time has prevented that
st. Helena Airport is not the world's
most useless Airport it is rather proven
that it has the potential to become the
world's most useful airport an airport
that could save lives revitalize an
economy and connect a forgotten dot on
the map to the rest of it an airport
that could rescue an island from falling
into the same fate of so many lives
crumbling into irrelevance as its people
are slowly drawn to the urban world so
now that the island has their tool all
they have to do is use it
[Music]
as I mentioned at the start this entire
project was made possible thanks to
curiosity stream they covered all the
enormous production expenses including
flying a team to st. Helena and all they
asked in return was for us to mention
the bundle deal they're running with
nebula the streaming site founded by
myself
and loads of other great creators and
where this documentary originally
released if you sign up for any
curiosity stream subscription at
curiosity stream comm slash Wendover
you'll not only get access to thousands
of top quality documentaries and TV
shows on there you'll also get a
subscription to nebula at no added cost
on nebula you'll find tons of great
original content - like this one from
the loads of the Internet's best
creators I can safely say this is the
best value in the streaming world so
head over to curiosity strum comm slash
Wendover to sign up for the bundle deal
and while you're at it you'll also be
helping support independent creators
create great ambitious projects just
like this
[Music]